watch carefully  [Music]  look at that oh boy  [ __ ] delicious  oh my lord i decided to teach a second  masterclass  oh boy this time round i'm going to take  you into an area where you felt your  home cooking could never go  [Music]  the secret behind any great souffle is  in the buttering of the mold  you brush vertical strokes up  [Music]  this crispy chicken salad for me is the  get out of jail card especially when  you've got a big dinner party because  that  is good enough for four or five of you  grab a leaf lift it up  now i'm fed up when you see chefs  boiling asparagus  beautiful you get a free facial at the  same time  cooking is a labor of love stay close to  every step of the way  i'm going to teach you methods secrets  that i'm teaching some of the best chefs  in the world today  i'm gordon ramsay and this is my master  class  you